foreign
who would you rather date your daughter
MLK by George Floyd who would you rather
date your daughter probably this guy
Bryce Hall I'll go with Bryce hall right
up next would you rather date your
daughter
um probably Martin Luther King you like
Martin Luther King yes they're both
black political activists yeah
what
who would you rather date your daughter
Andrew Tate or Jeffrey Epstein either
pick one no no I don't know I don't know
who the [__] this other guy is but [__]
interesting
I apologize I'm not educated on the
subject I don't have an opinion she
hated him but she didn't have an opinion
all right Trump or Hitler [__] this [__]
honestly wait what am I supposed to do
option are you kidding me right now
this should be easy
get a smash or pass what would you
rather date your daughter oh God neither
what the [__] why is this I crazy
because it was President you think he's
as bad as Hitler kill myself this
shouldn't be hard hopefully it's not but
who would you rather date your daughter
Donald Trump trump
um I would prefer that my daughter is
celibate she's not dating anybody I
honestly have to change my answer I
completely agree I agree yeah I agree
next one okay oh my God absolutely none
of them
either of them
why do you guys not like Andrew Tate
because he's a dude this is a weirdo
also what did he like what did he do
comment and he thinks that he owns them
he thinks he's the [__] and he's just
not men rule the [__] world they
don't want to admit it men control
everything and they can't and [__]
admit it dude okay they're delicious
Andrew said I saw Andrew take a picture
Andrew's trying to help us out that's
all it is Andrew tries to [__] help
the world escape the [__] Matrix
[__] guy get the [__] out of here
he's he's
my [__] boy
[Music]
dude I'm just doing my thing you know be
honest who would you rather date your
daughter all right
all right well I'm Jewish so I gotta say
him you're Jewish okay yeah so like that
would be kind of like it shouldn't be a
tough decision
would you rather date your daughter I
got I gotta is this a tough one is this
hard yeah
yeah
[Music]
that's the [__] go dude you don't get
no much better than that that's my
daughter dating Andrew trait keep her in
place what the [__] else do you want
from that dog he's taking care of keep
it the [__] real y'all take my daughter
our daughter him
wait do you know who they are no okay
that's like you can't leave that in then
all right next one okay
who would you rather date your daughter
ah uh Donald Trump Donald Trump yeah
isn't it pretty concerning that that's
like a tough question for a lot of
people yeah a lot of them are like
neither yeah they just walk away yeah
not
real quick it's everyone's dream
nowadays to make a living off of making
videos online and I've been doing this
for two full years now so I know
basically everything that goes into it
with that I'm opening up more spots to
my free newsletter to teach all of you
guys how to do the same there's a
thousand new spots open right now each
video I do this they fill up crazy quick
so don't waste time right away you'll
get sent over four cheat codes that have
gotten me to where I am today and then
from there I'll just be sending daily
emails dropping some free sauce there's
no risk to signing up just make sure
you're quick all right I'm Gonna Leave
the link at the top of the description
back to the video so who would you
rather date your daughter
Bella I hate Andrew Jane why why do you
hate Andrew Tate why do you like him he
spreads a really positive message for
men and especially how to protect and
provide for women but why don't you like
you don't need protecting me don't be
providing
but sexist what did I do
who pays the bill
a few moments later
I would actually pay for a cigarette I'm
not kidding would you say the n-word for
a cigarette
hell [__] no I'm a raging liberal
you're a raging liberal yeah so like all
the flags and [__] you're all pro that I
live for it I'm actually clearly don't
live well if you're not a liberal
you're canceled do you want to have a
little debate roast me stick to roast I
need a steak to roast you need to take
the road it comes out with a cig I need
a cigarette we're not even doing this
like they're a lost cause
I'm a lost cause
are you a liberal too
obviously
there's something wrong with the
bisexuals no nothing wrong with the
bisexuals wake me up baby I'll roast I
don't like out of you here come here
come on light me up [__] oh
[__] you
I got played
Andrew Tate or Osama bin Laden
awesome
you'd rather Osama Bin Laden date your
daughter than Andrew Tate yeah
[Music]
Donald Trump do you like you sounds like
you like Trump I don't like Trump but I
don't know Vladimir Putin's just not who
would you rather no comment if one of
these people had to Baby babysit your 12
year old daughter who would you rather
not the one on the left
Michael Jackson
you'd rather Michael Jackson I don't
know what the other one is but I'm not
looking so all right thank you girls all
right what's up with you which one would
you rather you have this beautiful beach
are you in this dude now yeah watch out
honey excuse me relax buddy relax buddy
relax
are we good what's mommy yeah let's run
the interview oh okay do you wanna I
mean are you okay with that okay do you
wanna is that cool are we good sorry
we're good am I being mean I don't know
I I didn't know what's on the camera was
probably
yeah let's go yeah who would you rather
date your daughter by Andrew Tate he
looks like this guy so he's probably a
stand-up guy
[Music]
yes sir
ask everyone
this [__] yo yo yo
yo yo
come on bro relax
my [__] phone and stuff yeah
I get my [__] out of here yeah yeah yeah
[__] you oh
don't press my butt [__] you I'm not
pressing nobody you guys are coming up
to me
broke bro yeah all right
bro can you just leave us alone bro
all right what's your name
bro you guys are acting like like
Goombas bro it wasn't us
come on
I'm not trying to be some [__] whop
out here telling you give this kid an
interview and give you some [__] no no
that's not even it we want to do the
interview real quick it's it's like for
girls like it's not like you guys don't
have as good as reactions it's not dude
come on we got the interview you said
Tate and [__] who would you rather date
your daughter
Donald Trump or Vladimir Putin
is this hard
come on one two three
Vladimir Putin next one again oh [__]
I'm panicking you're panicist who would
you rather date your daughter Andrew
Tate or Osama Bin Laden Andrew J Andrew
Tate do you like entertain no [__] now
[__] no [__] okay last one who would you
rather date your daughter George Floyd
or MLK George Floyd George Floyd
two black activists no I know uh no I'm
fixed racism for the better I'm gonna
you want to like explain why I don't
know okay thank you these two guys like
basically fixed racism I bet so who
would you rather George Floyd or MLK
date your daughter
okay yeah
okay would you want to say why well he
had like a lifelong Legacy to leave
unfortunately no one knew who George
Floyd was until the incident who would
you say left a bigger impact and was a
bigger hero I don't know honestly both
of them in the long run I have a dream
yeah I don't know in the long run who
left a bigger impact both of them why
are you seven
George Floyd but hey that though I think
both left to produce
who would you rather exactly like you
huh would you rather date your daughter
George later I'm okay oh MLK I cannot
believe the answers We Got Tonight what
a night in Boston I'll see you [__]
[Music]
foreign